hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chainsenses.com so this is day number
nine guys in my crotching hotel i can't
wait to be out of
here i want to get back to my place get
back to my gears my accesses everything
so i would be able to even give you more
videos so in today's video i would like
to go
with you through yesterday's press
action on amc see everything that we had
we had some very interesting information
i will discuss it with you guys and of
course i will give you all my different
scenarios
so let's get into it
[Music]
so as you know i'm following even more
closely amc's price action seats
i quit my job so i usually was starting
on the first time frame now i'm usually
starting in a 15 minutes time frame
so i'm zooming in everything um checking
with you
all the information that this press
action is sending us here
so as usual i'm gonna start reminding
you what i was saying in my previous
video
so basically i was telling you guys we
have three
scenarios so the first one being uh we
get rejected
around 44. go back
right away to the 38 40 area 10 months
back
the second one was we go to the 50 area
then correct and bounce back
so actually what happened is a bit
between so i posted this level on my
discord guys
just before it happened so i will keep
on updating you guys with intraday price
action
at least around the open because as you
know i am in hong kong
so i can't stay here all the training
session
i need to sleep sometimes and here i
gave you guys the 46.5 level
and to be honest i was saying in my
analysis that if we go there we would
probably break it
and we didn't break it so we're gonna
analyze here everything that happened
i was telling you as well that we are
looking for small bearish divergences to
know guys
when this price action might revert and
here you can see that on the 15 minute
time frame we get
one but i was saying on my discord check
the hourly
i think the hourly is more trustful on
the hourly
time frame as you can see guys we don't
have this
divergence we have kind of a flat
between
here and here between the two lows so
it's close to an exaggerated divergence
no it's not even an exaggerated
divergence because it's the macd making
effect
so here no information so this is what i
was saying telling you
so as you can see 46.5 acted perfectly
guys as resistance so once again i found
this level
because it's a consolidation area in the
last
move down so what are the different
possibilities from here so as you can
see it seems to me that
this so i'm going to come back to this
very soon
it seems to me that this first impulse
is complete
so the first thing is that we want to
see five waves because if we only have
three waves it looks like a correction
when you have five waves it looks like a
motive waves but
keep in mind that we could of course
have something like this as well it
could still be a big abc and then we
correct so i'm gonna come to this
scenario very soon
for now i want to go through what
happened here
during the day i'm a bit surprised that
we got rejected at 46.5 to be honest all
right i'm gonna explain here why i told
you guys this in my discord a lot of you
just told me we don't understand what
you're talking about
so i'm gonna explain here in more detail
so basically
once you have wave one identified
clearly then you have the second wave
being itself
a one two three four five or you know
you can always do the three like this
you know
here i can see that the third wave is
going here because here i have a deeper
correction so let's keep the
counting like this and then you are
wondering how far
the fifth swap is gonna go this is a
setup that we often have
in training we know it's bullish but we
you know yesterday everybody knew it was
bullish during the open session
everybody was like yeah
following and just trying to buy in
seashells because everyone
was feeling the bullish momentum that
we're having
then it faded of course but we had some
very
strong moves around the open and how far
this fifth wave can go so to answer this
question you measure
everything between wave one and wave
three
and you apply it to the bottom of the
force then you go to the elliot wave
bible
so you guys know how to find it you go
in this
place so here you have different
situation with three wave five and wave
one extension
but to be honest i don't use that so
much i prefer to use this
which is a more general rule as a
generalization that subsumes
some of the observations we have already
made unless we won the extended blah
blah blah
and here you having the only two cases
that sum up the whole situation for an
impulse
so either we have a fifth wave that is
38.2 and the rest is 61.8
or we have a fixed wave that is 61.8 and
the
rest is 38.2 so to know what is the
ratio of the fifth wave compared
to one plus three that we're doing here
guys
it's very basic mathematical formula
in the first here you just divide by one
plus three which length is 61.8
and you divide what the the length of
the fifth wave
okay so 38.2 divided by
and it gives you 61.8 percent and in the
second case
as you can see it's 61.8 divided by 28.2
and give 1.618 so that's why
those are the field extension ratios
that
i'm targeting for my fifth waves
compared to the bottom of the false
wave so this is exactly sorry this is my
discord by the way
this is exactly what i'm playing here i
measure from zero
to three and i applied to the bottom of
the force and you can see
that the 61.8 is 49.5
and the 1.618 is much higher at 63.
so as we're coming from the lows and we
have an extended third
i was more thinking about the 61.8 so my
target was here
okay we failed to go there it happens we
went to the 38.2
retracement which is not the usual case
but it can happen all right so
i would have preferred to see the fixed
wave going higher but it's fine like
this we have here a small bearish
divergence and then
we come back to my different scenarios
we correct so what can we expect from
here
good question so as you guys know this
is complete
so right now we're expecting an abc
okay so either we have something like
this
and then we go higher so in this case
i measure actually the first wave that
is complete
and we know guys that second waves if
the zigzags they like to correct
to the 61.8 retracement level so if we
go to 61.8
we would go to 37 even all right so
it's not my perfect case because i think
38
would hold here but we might see some
excesses below 38
it would still be fine for me so all the
37
40 area is the area where i would be a
buyer
of amc for today's session and friday's
session if we have a flat we could have
something like this
so we could still go to the 40 the 40
area would probably be revisited one
more time before we move higher
this would be a second wave what else is
possible it's still possible that we
have a force that is like this
okay and that the fifth goes higher this
is on the table
then the fib extensions would be
okay this would make more sense this
would be a typical
first wave impulse so this is very
possible as well
i give this scenario a high probability
i will give all the details of the
probabilities that are associated to all
of my scenarios in my discord yes so go
there and you will see
each probability that at my personal
levels you know i just try to give you
my best estimates of the likeliness of
each scenario so here
this is my preferred scenario this will
make more sense for me and then we
correct
if this happens then we would correct
somewhere here
and then move probably higher we could
also be as you guys just saw
this is complete and we're having a
second wave that is
going here here so basically what i'm
expecting
either a last wave up and then a
correction
or a slightly deeper correction and then
a move up and
what we need to discuss guys that is
very important is that
as you can see here i'm showing you the
bullish case
that we go to 135 you know 100 125 you
know my targets
but we have one more strong resistance
that we need to trade
above i think we're going to get
rejected in the first place so the third
wave would probably be something like
this
you know we would have here some kind of
rejection it would not be like this
actually
but we would here i think find some
rejection some consolidation
so we can expect even if we go here
today to have something like this and
then we break
we test and we go higher as we always do
guys so
here i would say we need to be a bit
careful in the 50 area this is
definitely not a good level to buy
of course the good level to balance
would be just after this
first wave is definitely complete which
is now not hundred percent sure then we
correct and then we move higher and here
question guys
so here we're gonna see i'm gonna stay
with you guys in my discord
when amc would be close to this levels
i'm gonna analyze with you what we are
seeing
where we're gonna look as usual for
breakouts divergences field extensions
ratios stuff like this that is gonna
lead us on the right path
so that's it for mc let me quickly do
game stop here because i know that some
of you guys want to see gamestop as well
so not much to say to be honest i'm
gonna stay on the hourly time frame i
told you guys
that here we broke 180 that was the
major support we did
some kind of a fake out here and then we
broke it
and we are retesting it right now so i
don't think the first wave is complete i
think we're gonna go to 205 to
this trendline then correct and then
move higher if you want more information
go in my discord i'm posting daily
recaps
everything is still for free at least
for one week so you're gonna have all
the information that you guys need you
can ask me questions about anything
i'm making some analysis about different
stocks so just come here to ask me any
questions so guys that's it for me i
hope you enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and
bell button so you're gonna be the first
to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys